heute sprechen wir über werben mit zwei
objekten
bei
mit akkusativ und dativ haben wir
folgende drei regeln
regel nummer
wenn man
zwei namen als objekte hat dann gilt
dativ objekt vor akkusativ objekt
regel nummer
wenn man
und ein pronomen hat dann gilt kurz vor
lang das bedeutet das pronomen kommt
immer vor dem nomen
regel nummer
wenn man zwei pronomen als objekte hat
dann gilt akkusativ objekt vor dativ
objekt
hier kommen
der mann
einer freundin einen ring
der mann schenkt seiner freundin einen
ring
der mann schenkt ihr einen ring
der mann schenkt ihn seiner freundin
der mann schenkte ihn seiner freundin
der mann schenkt ihm ihr
der mann schenkt ihnen ihr
sie schreibt ihre
da einen brief
sie schreibt ihrer mutter einen brief
sie schreibt ihr einen brief
sie schreibt ihn
mutter
da mutter
sie schreibt ihn ihr
[Musik]
mutter kaufte ihrem sohn ein plüschtier
kauft ihrem sohn ein plüschtier
die muss
kauft ihm ein plüschtier
[Musik]
die mutter kaufte ihm ein plüschtier
die mutter kaufte es ihrem sohn
die mutter
die mutter kann
daniel gibt tina einen kurs
dani
gibt ihr einen kurs
daniel gibt ihr einen kurs
daniel gibt ihn tina
daniel gibt in china
daniel gibt ihm ihr
daniel gibt ihn ihr
der großvater erzählt den enkeln eine
geschichte
der großvater erzählt ihnen eine
der großvater erzählt sie den enkeln
der großvater erzählt sie ihnen
er schickt julian eine sms
rahel schickt julian eine sms
rahel schickt ihm eine sms
rahel schickt sie julian
rahel schickt sie ihm
alles klar
super dann seid ihr an der reihe
bildet den satz
subjekt das mädchen
werk wünschen
akkusativ objekt einen hund
da tief objekt sich
[Musik]
genau das mädchen wünscht sich einen
hund
nächster satz
subjekt der kellner
verb empfehlen
akkusativ objekt einen wein
da tief
dem paar
[Musik]
richtig der kellner empfiehlt dem paar
einen wein
richtig der k
er empfiehlt dem paar einen wein
und der letzte satz
subjekt der mann
verbringen
akkusativ
da tief objekt ihr
[Musik]
perfekt der mann bringt ihm ihr
perfekt der mann bringt ihn ihr
[Musik]
zum schluss noch ein
einen tipp bei werben mit akkusativ und
dativ ist das dativ objekt in der regel
eine person
so das war's
tschüss bis zum 9
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten möchtest du noch weitere
videos sehen dann abonniere unseren
kanal jeden sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video